[Music]
all right everybody here we are here we
go and everybody needs to congratulate
Jacob who is one of the moderator than
the moderator of the Facebook group and
who just had two baby girls adding to
his growing clan and so he said he's
gonna be in and out of the chat and so
thanks for coming Jacob despite I
imagine that you're drowning in diapers
and and also in a lack of sleep so I'm
happy to see you in the chat room happy
to see Christian Chad back in the chat
room again as our moderator he was gone
he wasn't there last month oh it's good
to see him Lisa is also there she's
running the clip channel you know guys I
wanted to do two to really call
attention to that Lisa and I've Lassa I
not try pronouncing his name right last
side they're running this clip channel
for me and it's just been really amazing
they've been putting stuff out you know
everyday I think they're gonna slow down
a little bit because they were just
putting out video after video after
video short clips kind of picking stuff
out of the question and answers picking
stuff out of old videos that maybe most
people haven't seen trying to trying to
feature that stuff and so you know go
and subscribe to that channel cuz it's
it's they're really doing a great job
and Lisa is also really hilarious she
put together a few really funny videos
that I hope that we'll see more and more
so so yeah so that's going on I have a
few announcement another another few
other announcements okay I am going to
be in Boston on the 15th of February at
the Greek Orthodox Cathedral I'll be
giving a full day of of talks to talks
plus also we're going to do a tour of
the church and looking at the
iconography and everything there's a
lunch that's provided it's super cheap I
forget how much it is I think it's like
$15 for like the whole day and lunch is
included so check that out on my website
on my events page you'll find that and
also a way to sign up for for that day
I am going to be giving a conference in
Seattle May 3rd
again with shared inheritance like last
year I gave a conference there so on on
May 3rd there's going to be a full day I
think they're doing like two days again
of talks and I will also be giving a
week of carving there so after that
event after May 3rd that whole week
following is going to be a carving
workshop for those who would like to do
that
so at the carving workshops are a lot of
fun because you know you come to the
workshop we carve during the day and
then we you know we also chat it's a
good time to to get into kind of you
know longer discussions we end up
talking about symbolism it ends up being
a lot of fun by the end of the week
everybody is friends it's really cool
so if you can in Seattle come to that
carving workshop the the event is not up
on my event page yet but it will appear
very soon with a way to sign up you can
check out the shared inheritance website
I'm sure that the the event is going to
appear there very soon I will also be
giving a class a carving class in
Connecticut from May 31st to June 6th
near it's near Hartford or ideas in
Hartford same thing check out my website
I'll keep announcing it but I haven't
put up these things because some of the
details aren't out yet but if you are in
that area I would say guys you know you
know it's it's like I said carving
workshops are just such a great time if
you want to do a deep dive and have long
discussions we're there all day and
especially in Hartford we're gonna be
carving in the evening as well people
stay there so we carve in the evenings
and so and so it ends up being like
really long days carving it during the
day and in the evening having a few
drinks sometimes smoking a cigar or
something and also in Seattle they
usually have cigar nights if you like
cigars that's fun too alright so I think
that that's enough announcements for now
let's get into the questions ok so we
have a problem
we have a problem which I guess I should
have seen coming and is that right there
I counted there are 37 questions in the
different of the different websites you
know on patreon on subscribe star on on
on my website as you know people get
ten dollars a month on patreon they get
to ask questions in advance but now it's
like there are just too many questions I
can't I'm not gonna get through all
those questions so here's the rule what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go through the
questions my first mechanism to sort out
the questions is going to be I'm going
to if you if people have written two
questions I'm gonna pick only one
question per person then I'm also going
to skip the questions that have
super-long text you know elaborating the
person's opinion sometimes it can be
interesting but just because for time
and everything I'm going to I'm going to
I'm going to avoid those so anti saint
asks me where's the bow tie and the bow
tie is you know Amanda book there's
something you know when you're somewhere
when in Rome you can act like the Romans
but when you're not in Rome then it's
weird to act if I were a bow tie around
here it'd be very odd but uh but I might
wear it again you know I got it I got a
lot of positive comments about the bow
tie all right so we need to start
because you don't start will never never
end I'm thinking I'll probably I'll
probably go for like an hour and a half
maybe we'll see how it goes we'll see
how much energy I can muster all right
so I'm going to start with the website
as usual all right so Keenan Cronin asks
I struggle with how much of a difference
there is between the level of wealth and
comfort we have in our world and
Christ's come in to give away our
possessions to help the poor and the way
the early church seems to behave in acts
how do you handle this what are your
views on charity in relation to Christ's
example so I think the way to understand
it there are two ways to understand what
isn't understanding it in terms of
hierarchy you know there still is this
idea of giving everything to follow
Christ that's what a monk does so monks
you know they have no possessions in
theory even the things that they use are
not theirs they're their bishop you know
they're they're Abbot has full control
over what objects they can or can't use
and so they they are
possessed and they live the life of a
poor person and so that is still there
in the Christian Church you still have
it it's just that the way that it set
itself up in order to give place for the
world to exist is is in a hierarchy and
so if you're interested in the question
there is a really nice little text from
the early church by by st. clement of
rome called who is the rich person who
will be saved and the basic idea in his
text and i think it's become the basic
trope of christianity we see in saint
paul he talks about that as well he said
st. paul talks about how he can be rich
or poor like he can live in different
circumstances that is the idea is not
that you have to be poor you know that
the idea of poverty is to divest
yourself of your possessions in order to
be fully dependent on God to to be not
dependent on these garments of skin that
we have around us but it is possible it
may be harder but it is also possible
for someone who is wealthy to use his
wealth generously and to care for those
around him and to care for the poor and
that also is part of how everything kind
of lays itself out and so the best way
like I said to see it is through a
hierarchy and so if you're not willing
to give up everything and live as a you
know become a monk then you can at least
use what you have to help those around
you all right so david Flores asks I
just finished listening to laughter what
is the connection between lancelot skill
at arms and his devotion to Gwenevere
I'd assumed it was something like purity
of spirit manifesting purity of combat
prowess however his love for her has
adulterous undertones also video on
Gawain and the Green Knight
I think you've asked that before there
David the way that I see the way that I
see the problem of Lancelot there are a
few ways one is to understand that in
fact he
is his love for Guinevere is his is his
flaw in a way you know it is his
motivation and there's something about
it you know which if it if it had
remained pure there would be something
about it which could be which could be
good but because it ends up becoming
adultery then it ends up being his flaw
and it also ends up being his demise and
participates in the demise of the of the
round table and is also you know the
reason why he's not able to find the
Grail is because of his adulterous
relationship so it ends up being his
thorn to a certain in a certain manner
but there's also something else going on
in that story the whole um the whole
question of Lancelot we also have to
understand that Lancelot is French and
you know there's a there's a there's
also a relationship between Lancelot as
the this foreign knight who comes from
France and then the fact that the king
is cold I'm gonna make a video on that
pretty soon on the idea of because I've
seen people ask that in the in the chat
I see a lot of the are a lot of they'll
it's a hard writer right wing people who
talk about how Christianity is a cuckold
religion and how Joseph is a cuckold and
you know you see in the popular culture
people talking about that quite a bit
and so I think that I'm probably gonna
make a video about that very soon
something like is Christianity a cuckold
religion and then we can talk a little
bit about that maybe I can even use the
example of Lancelot in that video to try
to to show different patterns of of
cuckolding and what they can mean all
right so Jessie Blaine he says what's
the significance of early Christians
using the sign of a fish to identify
themselves so the way the way that so he
gives his own theory but I won't read it
the the way that you need to understand
fish is you see it in the gospel you
need if you look at how the fish are
described in the gospel I mentioned this
a little bit in a recent talk I think
are in
in QA the idea is that you you have like
potentiality you know you have this this
see out of which the world comes so you
you can imagine it you know in the Old
Testament God calls for the you know
pull the earth out of the sea and then
basically it's like creations being
pulled out of the sea from logos pulling
from potentiality so that the world
manifests itself and so that is what the
fisherman is ultimately doing so the
fisherman is putting his net into the
sea and he's pulling out the nuggets the
hidden things that can participate in
reality he's pulling them out those that
are that can become food for the world
let's say and so you can imagine in
terms of in terms of Christianity that
when let's say when Christ tells st.
Peter that he's going to become a Fisher
of men is that he he's basically taking
fish out of the ocean so that it becomes
food for God or that another way to say
it saying it becomes food for God is odd
but saying that it becomes the body of
God and so that is what we are called to
be we are called to be this food for God
that in the sense that we are there we
are the potential we are that the
possibility is in which God manifests
himself and so if you can imagine it as
the sea as this this let's say place of
kind of of dark potentiality and then
hidden inside are these little shiny
things and these little shiny things are
like the spark of the divine that are
able to kind of be pulled out of the of
the chaos in order to participate in
reality so I hope that makes sense so
the idea of of the fish is basically the
idea of life in death right of of life
that is hidden in death kind of like
seeds you know until you know in the
ground there are these seeds that are
hidden and that will bring up the tree
and so in the ocean in this dead thing
and this thing which represents kind of
death and chaos
there's food that you can get and bring
up and make participate in the world and
so you as
fish you know people who get tattoos or
fish or how the early Christian
represented themselves as fish it has to
do with that it has to do with the idea
of this life hidden in death and so it
has to do with the resurrection you know
it ultimately also refers to something
like Jonah who who was in hidden in the
fish you know just like st. Peter goes
into the ocean and it goes into the sea
and then he finds a gold piece inside
the fish so this idea of value hidden in
potentiality the fish hidden in the
ocean you know Jonah hidden in the whale
you know if you want to refer to a
another video that I've done let's say
about Christmas the idea of the hidden
gift you know the the orange hidden in
the sock during Christmas season you
know the hidden gift so that's what
that's what the fish has to do it
alright so Lisa asks hi Jonathan can
explain why John the Baptist father
Zechariah couldn't speak until his son's
birth it is said that it was because he
was skeptical of the pregnancy but what
does that have to do with an inability
to speak um well you could see it really
just directly in the sense that you know
God revealed himself to Zechariah and
Zechariah did not believe the vision and
so he could not speak you know and so
you can understand it in terms of just
the normal hierarchy to understand that
let's say there's the logos of God and
then we are the little Christians we are
the little Christ we are the we are the
the little the sons of God and so we
manifest the logos in the world but if
we don't connect if we're not connected
to the divine logos then we can't speak
or you know we or we say nonsense or we
don't you know we're not we're not we're
not we can no longer the vehicles for
the divine logos to manifest in the
world so I think that the fact that he
doubted the logos he doubted this
revelation that he received from God and
so therefore it prevented him to speak
because that's that is from where we
speak we
ultimately we speak the our logos our
capacity of mind and of speech and of of
language is is a lower version isn't a
not is analogous to the divine logos all
right okay so do so s LS 94 ask a few
questions that we'll just take the first
one what is the symbolism of Joseph's
going to Egypt becoming the advisor of
the Pharaoh his family returning to him
to live in Egypt and his sons being
blessed by Israel as his own
if this mirrors Christ's death and
resurrection then why is Jesus born to
the tribe of Benjamin Jesus isn't born
to the tribe of Benjamin Jesus is born
of the tribe of Judah I'm not sure sorry
man
I think you might have you might have
you might not have phrased your question
properly so I don't know what to say I'm
not sure I'm not sure how to answer that
okay so why tier 2 asks when God is
refined and Gideon's army he has Gideon
send away the men that cup water in
their hands to drink rather than
kneeling to drink is there a significant
symbolic difference between bringing
water to your mouth to drink it out of
your hands as opposed to kneeling to
drink it directly from the source okay
so this is this is what I think this is
really my speculation and I've thought
about this quite a bit in terms of
understanding why that's wet because it
is a strange detail in the story I think
that it has to do with the idea of the
idea of because in in Genesis they
separate the waters there's a waters
above and the waters below and I've kind
of talked about this this problem of the
you know you have the waters above you
have the waters below the water that
come from above are like blessing and
the water that are below are like
potentiality you could say and so the
idea so for example you see that in the
symbolism of baptism you see that there
is the other of these two traditions the
one tradition which
that baptism is going down into the
waters below and that you see that
closer in the symbolism of the the
Orthodox baptism and the Protestant
baptism and then you have this idea that
baptism is actually being sprinkled from
the waters above and then you see that
in Catholic baptism if you look at early
images it seemed like it was both at the
same time if you look at if you look at
early images you can see Christ pouring
water John the Baptist pouring water
over Christ's head but then Christ also
being in the water at the same time and
the early baptistry seemed to have had
often had the baptistry and then there
was like a fountain that would come up
and so if you were in the back to the
baptistry you you would have a a ount in
over your head and then you would also
be in the waters and so what's important
is understand that these two different
types of waters one which is coming from
above like a blessing one which is below
like potentiality and so I think that
that's what it has to do with it has to
do with the fact that that those who
lift the water up to their mouth they
are of heaven you could say or they they
you know they manifest their their
connection to heaven whereas those that
kneel down they put their face in the
water then they connect their where they
are manifesting their relationship to
earth you would say something like that
um that's as good as it get it's gonna
get because it is indeed a strange a
strange
a strange part of the text alright so I
am done with the website questions I
will move on to subscribe star
okay so Nicola asks you talked a lot
about the masculine and feminine so does
Jordan Peterson what would be your
definition of masculine and feminine
how do those term relate to male and
female and how are they different and so
I mean in terms of masculine and
feminine male and female you know
masculine is a broader category because
there are things that are masculine and
are not you know there are
there are things that are masculine but
that are not necessarily male in terms
of cosmic like the cosmic structure you
could say and there are things that are
feminine and an art not necessarily
female so I mean one a simple example is
in language you know we have these
gender terms not in English but in
French and many other languages where
some things are masculine some things
are feminine I mean obviously they're
not male and female they don't then
they're not biological beings you know
but they are masculine feminine you know
so I thought a lot about and I think
I've been asked in the question period
whether or not there is some meaning in
this masculine feminine words I think
that maybe long long ago there was I'm
not sure if there still is it seems like
that's a that if there symbolism there
seems to have devolved quite a bit but
the potential of the idea that in the
identity of certain things there would
some things are more masculine and some
things are for feminine now as to what
is the relationship between the two we
have to go back again in the story of
Genesis and understand this separation
of heaven and earth as this existence or
that this first reality of heaven and
earth as the primal duality as the yin
and the yang as the active and passive
as the you know the you could call it
the question and the answer in terms of
the feminine being a question the male
being answer you could have logos
proposed so you really do have to
understand it as the primordial opposite
now the problem is that I'm not going to
be able to give you a full definition of
what masculine feminine is because it is
the very pattern of reality it it
underlies all our opposites so you could
say it that way that the the the
primordial opposite underlies all our
opposites and so you can't define it you
can just point to it and and give
analogies of it so that you can
understand and so you can so a good way
to understand it would be to understand
look
at traditional culture the gender roles
that would exist in agent in a in a
traditional culture will show you what
masculine and feminine is and what it
what what the patterns of these
behaviors are how they are complimentary
how they are opposite and then
ultimately that can help you understand
the primordial opposition the the
primordial opposite let's say the first
opposite which is beyond all it's
actually beyond all description so I
hope this helps you know it's hard
because it is it's hard to define these
things we always end up talking around
them but some of the examples that I
gave I think are good enough to get you
started on that question
all right so XRD hi Jonathan what's the
significance behind the Bible's
prohibition against divination is it
seen as an intrusion on God's realm or
is there more to it the the relationship
the relationship in the Bible between
the the relationship in the Bible to
divination is actually more ambiguous
than you would think it is actually not
at all a straightforward thing the I'd
mentioned this in a recent video the
effort the ephod I know you pronounce it
was this cloth that the priests wore but
then also seems to have existed in other
circumstances where there were 12 stones
on the cloth and it seems like those
twelve stones might have been used in a
way maybe they were thrown maybe they
were ID who knows how they were used and
then you they were there were objects of
divination and so you could read the
will of God in the stones and so for
example like in the Bible when it says
something like and God said this God
said that God said this it's most
probably a best way to understand it is
through some form of divination that is
that the priests cast lots
using these stones and they had a sacred
language of reading the stones and they
could understand what the will of
was and so but why is divination frowned
upon and why is it dangerous I think
that the the problem of divination is
that it is usually motivated by
something like what you said it's
usually motivated by our desire to
control the future by our desire to
control events by our desire to have to
have an insight which is related to the
world that is it's almost like it's like
you want God's insight for the world
rather than getting let's say entering
into the life of God himself
it's like you want to get some of that
higher insight in order to know - in
order just to understand the patterns
but you know it's not it's not like I'll
be totally honest with you divination is
not completely frowned upon even in the
New Testament you know there's the story
of the Apostles and when you know when
Stephen dies then they want to sorry
with not what Stephen dies sorry when
they want to replace Judas they need to
find the Twelve Apostles and they end up
whittling it down
and finally they cast lots in order to
decide and that casting Lots
is a form of divination you know and in
the in the Orthodox Church even until
today I was told that this is the
similar process can happen that you know
the let's say a synod of Bishops will
get together and try to choose a
metropolitan or someone who is above the
bishops it would be like the head bishop
for those who don't know that language
and the way they do it would be to try
to find it you know to try to discern
the will of God and to pray to to it to
be able to find who is the right one but
if they can't agree then ultimately they
will also cast lots and that cats have
lots is a form of divination so so yeah
so I mean obviously the idea of going to
fortune-teller all that stuff is not is
definitely frowned upon because it is
this desire it is it is
which is turned towards towards the
material world trying to master the
future master the material world and it
can be very dangerous for you very
dangerous for your your soul to want to
do that and to use spiritual insight
just in order to gain power over the
world so I think that's probably the
best reason why divination that I think
why divination is is bad so Julie pain
asks Jonathon I've been thinking about
the particular phrase in the Lord's
Prayer that mentions earth and heaven in
light of the vastness of the symbolism
of heaven and earth I'm wondering if
your what are your thoughts on that part
of the prayer that kingdom come that
will be done on earth as it is in heaven
um I think that I think that this is
really a like the key to reality I mean
it really is the the key to
understanding the purpose of creation
the purpose of the incarnation that
that's what that's what it's about the
about the purpose of everything is so
that we become reflections we become
vessels for the divine to shine in the
world that we become let's say
translucent vessels of light that so
that's what it is so so when we talk
about the idea so you can imagine
Kingdom as so you have a king at the top
and then you have the kingdom and the
Kingdom it's like you imagine like a
pyramid or like a mountain at the king
above and then you have the kingdom
below and so what you want is you want
for the will of the king to reach all
the way down into the kingdom so that
the kingdom is the kingdom right the
kingdom is is the reign of the king it's
nothing else it is the extent to which
the king reigns and so you can
understand that the notion of Kingdom in
terms of anything right in terms of any
organization in terms of any identity
that there is an identity there's a
prince there's a principal and then
there's the let's say the the rule of
that principle on reality and so the
idea of Christianity and the idea as
opposed to something like that
more decadent aspects of platonism or
even of of Gnosticism is that we don't
believe that there's an opposition
ultimately like we don't believe that
it's only with that which is above which
is good it's only the ideas it's only
the divine principles it's only you know
the the higher things which are good and
the lower things are dirty and bad and
you know they're they're a kind of kind
of degradation of of reality rather we
believe that it's above you know on
earth as it is in heaven that the divine
logos fills the world completely and
that even the lowest aspects of reality
can be can be can be saved and that's
why Christ goes down into death you know
he leaves he goes all the way down into
the bottom of death to gather everything
up to God and that is this kingdom which
reaches to the ends of the earth which
reaches to the end of reality which
fills up the world and so it's really
important to understand that because
they're they're even even it's you know
there still is in popular thinking this
idea that somehow Christianity is anti
manifestation that Christianity's you
know hates the world hates the body all
of these things and this is of course
not at all true it own things only have
to be in the right order and the body
has in order for the body to be good it
has to become a kingdom alright alright
so Christian Chad our moderator says hi
Jonathan what do you think Christianity
has to say about erotic love I feel like
Christianity does not have a coherent
narrative to encompass it although I
will admit this might just be a Catholic
stereotype so one of the things one of
the difficulties in this whole problem
of erotic love is that you know
Christianity has been run by monks which
is very good this is what it's supposed
to be and so what happens in patristic
literature is that we see that the
erotic imagery that we find in the Old
Testament for example song
for example even in the Christian story
of God of the of the bridegroom and the
bride that this all this imagery becomes
this image this that becomes symbolic
for the relationship of God to the soul
and so the lover is God and the love
either the the woman is the human person
is the human soul or is the church and
so we have this relationship of this
erotic relationship between God and and
the person and if you read in the church
fathers it really is and in the Mystics
there is often a use of sexual imagery
that rapture this kind of rapturous
entry into no entry entry into God is
described as in sexual categories and
erotic categories now which you'll find
in the Church Fathers sometimes it's
like a warning which is that you know
that the the Song of Songs is this
relationship of the of God to the soul
and to be careful you know not to apply
it too much to actual erotic love but
you can't avoid it you just can't you
can't avoid it because you if you don't
have that reference if you don't have if
you don't have the reference of erotic
love then you you can't sublimate it
into the relationship between God and
the soul you have to maintain the
reference because then what are you
talking about it doesn't mate doesn't
mean anything anymore so I think the way
that I see it is that I think that that
reality of understanding that let's say
the song of songs as this poem you know
of the relationship between God and and
the human soul as this erotic
relationship and this kind of
dispassionate giving up into the other I
think that then that can actually come
back down and also participate in in a
normal marriage relationship you know of
course it cannot be coming exclusively
but it's
like you could having been filled with
this spiritual reality I think that it
can then come back down and participate
in in the life of a couple you know
understanding like I've talked a bit
about before in terms of sexuality
understanding that all the Logie have to
be come together and so that that there
is no place in Christianity at least not
in traditional Christianity there is no
place for a kind of errata sysm which
does not include fruitfulness you know
that the the that the purpose you know
you cannot remove the the reproductive
purpose of of sexuality because then yes
you're missing a important aspect of
reality so all of these things kind of
have to come together and I think that
you know in the let's say in the early
modern times there has been especially
in Catholic circles I don't know an
Orthodox circles because I I grew up in
a Catholic history let's say that there
was an excess and trying to reduce
sexuality to reproduction you know and
so the Catholic Church kind of hounded
people and tried to reduce sexuality to
reproduction and I think that that is
probably honestly one of the reasons why
it flipped the other way this there's
all this excess because you there is an
erotic aspect to sexuality you can't you
if you try to deny it it's going to
build up and it's going to explode
into the kind of crazy world we are now
so I think balance as usual is the best
way to go about it
that's my alright so Christian Chad
because he's Christian Chad he gets two
questions nobody else
all right so Christian Chad also asked
hi Jonathan you've mentioned
post-modernism many times on this
channel
what is it Christians and traditions can
take repose modernism without destroying
hierarchies and categories um and I know
I think I think that post-modernism is
very useful I think it's useful in
destroying the certainty of modernism
it's useful in in destroying the toe tap
the toe tap the totalizing tendency of
the Enlightenment
and of reason it is it accurately points
to the limits of the of the modern
system and this kind of modern desire to
compass everything in discourse and so
it points to the points to the cracks in
discourse it points to the place where
discourse falls apart and so the only
thing the only problem with it is that
it it does it in a manner which is
subversive and non and doesn't embrace
hierarchy and I think that you know if
you take I thought Jack Danida would
roll in his grave but it's like jug
digging down with hierarchy it ends up
was something not bad although he would
he would think I'm crazy to say that but
I think it's the it's always the proper
understanding of hierarchy is that we
always understand hierarchy from top
down but we can also understand
hierarchy from the bottom up and that's
what I've been trying to show people is
that the coming together you know the
communion of the Saints also produces
the hierarchy and that hierarchy can be
seen as the head in the body from a book
you know from above down but they can
also see has the body gathering
manifesting the head above you know so
so to me hierarchy is the solution to
the two the two how to use
post-modernism in a way that that is not
as destructive all right so so Michael I
think we already had a question by you
know Michael Erickson asks I'm currently
reading through Exodus and I'm wondering
about the symbolism of the staff that
Aaron uses in Exodus 7:10 can be seen as
an example of how God flips things
around so that the bad becomes a symbol
for good etc and is it connected to the
snake in the garden or am I reading too
much in it no it's definitely I mean if
you read that story and you don't see
that that the that the staff turning
into a snake is uh is not related to the
snake in the garden I mean that would be
crazy
it is obviously related to the snake in
the garden and so you you have to you
have to understand this this idea so so
imagine it like this
I've talked about the right hand the
left hand I'm not gonna go in it too
much but if you haven't seen my video my
recent video on what is it called
iconography as the pattern of reality
where I talk about the left in the right
hand also the this recent patron only
video I talk about this as well so
there's the idea of solidity and and
let's say falling apart or breaking down
so solidity will you hold on to
something so you say you grab something
you make it you make it real grabbing on
to something or pointing at something
you know you you gather it together you
you something you can even think about
it in terms of just ideas like it's like
it's like I grasp that idea right I
grasp it
so when you grasp something it comes
together it solidifies it becomes
something solid act it's a it acts
vertically right and then when you let
go of something then it fragments and it
breaks down when you abandon when you
give up when you you know all of these
this other type of imagery that's what
gives the snake right that's what gives
the the the lack of solidity the
shifting the the shifting left and right
ok moving from one side to the other
without any direct path and so magic
like you have a straight path a crooked
path you have all this imagery and so
that's what it's referring to it's you
know in the garden that's what happens
you know the Adam and Eve at the top of
the garden they give in to opposites and
as they give in to the opposites then
they break down you know with the snake
down into the thorns but that is that's
just the pattern of reality it's not
good or bad it's it can also be used it
can be it can be used for good sometimes
you let go and then the snake can be
used as a as you know as a monster to
come and eat your enemy so it just
depends it just depends in that story it
shows this the two possibilities of of
grasping and solidifying letting go and
have
things become let's say chaotic
potential something like that so
hopefully that wasn't too abstract but I
think for those of you that have watched
several of my videos you will understand
that all right guys so I am going to so
they're more questions from other people
like I said I'm just going to just going
to focus I'm just gonna try to have one
question for everybody because I've got
a lot more questions to go so here goes
for patreon patreon alright so in
patreon I will start with Josiah
mcgarvey asks is it common among
Orthodox Christian and Catholics to
share the symbolic understanding and
worldview that people like you and your
brother have I know the symbolic
worldview is totally foreign to
evangelicals you know it's you know it's
not totally formed evangelicals there
are some exceptions I think there are
some exceptions of people who I've seen
some writings of people who seem to just
have this intuitive grasp of the
symbolism I think that sadly what
happens is that it never ends up being
grounded never finds ground in reality
it ends up being more like kind of these
visions that they have and the visions
are actually extremely well patterned
and have very powerful structure it's
just that it doesn't land in terms of
Anto so that person could maybe have
extremely powerful intuition and have
this whole struck for the garden and
everything in their in their vision but
then you know they go back to church and
then there's none of that in the church
right so I think that I think that this
is the way that I could see it I think
that the modernism has done a serious
job on Christianity all types of
Christianity the Orthodox and the
Catholics as well my experience is that
in the Orthodox Church I have found the
most people contemporary people
contemporary authors who
who agree with what I'm saying and and
understand that Christianity is talking
about this stuff you know you you see
people like father of schmayman you see
people like vladimir lossky you see you
know theologian like nellis like all
these all these contemporary orthodox
theologians they they have this symbolic
worldview now I don't think that they
felt the need to dissect it and explain
it the way that Metz you and I are doing
you know the reason why we feel the need
to do that is because we see that the
disease is so deep that there needs to
be a radical cure and so explaining it
is a dangerous thing we're not unaware
of the danger of explaining the
symbolism because you can mistake
explaining symbolism with living it and
but at this point I think a lot of
things are so far gone that we have to
explain it but a good way to understand
it that I have found nothing but
acceptance in the hierarchy of my church
with four things I'm saying and I am you
know I'm being invited to speak at
different events and you know this is
now this summer will be the second time
that I'm actually invited to speak at
the General Assemblies of the of the you
know the of the church with the priest
and the bishop and everything so so I
think that you know you're going to find
it at different levels depending on on
your circumstance all right so a gars
mom is asked hey Jonathan can you
elaborate on the symbolic idea of
business there seems to be a great
difference between being a master of a
particular trade and running a business
that is trying to oversee all the
processes are there any dangers in the
idea of business yes for sure there are
dangers in the idea business if you
understand you you have to understand
that for example in the Middle Ages
the businessman and the artisan were not
seen in the same class in traditional
societies business is always frowned
upon I'm sorry to say that it is that
frowned upon but it is seen as something
which is is a little dangerous for your
soul in the sense of you know a
craftsman is perfecting craft and it's
kind of living this thing and is doing
where as a businessman is often seen in
the kind of traditional way of seeing
things as as this kind of middle man who
buys themselves and is is actually just
actually just dealing in money really um
and so and so it does have a different
it does have a different connotation but
I think that the I think that the
businessman are the merchants I think
also has a function in the in the grand
scheme of things I think that they also
have a role to play and that they also
have a cosmic role let's say it has to
do with the capacity to gather
possibilities the the pot the capacity
to see opportunities the capacity to the
capacity to also a little bit the little
bit of the tricks there is in the idea
of the merchants somewhat there's this a
little bit of the idea of the trickster
in there being crafty in that sense you
know making a deal getting the best of
of what of what's there you know that
can be negative or positive it can also
be positive I think that all these
aspects of the business person is really
is quite important and you can see it in
in scripture you can see people who have
that capacity you know you have the
story of Jacob obviously who you know
who works for his brother as
brother-in-law Laban and is able to get
a pretty good deal you know by doing
certain maneuvers he's able to then get
get a bunch of you know get rich let's
say um in the Bible also the idea of
becoming rich
also has to do with kind of living in
the foreign land so you get your riches
from Egypt you know you get your you get
your region from you get your riches
from dealing with the outside and so
that can also be something that is
tricky all right so AJ doubt or you ask
hey Jonathan do you think the Orthodox
Church lets in enough of the new I think
that it's I think that it's a discussion
that that is constantly happening I
think one of the problems that we have
right now is that the world is
accelerating at such a pace that it
might seem to that that let's say
something an orthodoxy is just
completely static but that is not the
case orthodoxy all traditional worlds
are dynamic not that they change to
change that is stupid the idea that the
idea that you should let in something
new because it's new is stupid it is it
is a complete it's complete nonsense it
is it is it is a delusion of the modern
world to think that because something is
new then it has some value doesn't
things have value or they don't now if
something new appears you know the the
that novelty will be measured against
the tradition and it will be in if it
can be integrated and if it can add
something then it will be integrated you
know and you can see the Orthodox
tradition as this has this accumulative
process you know because it's not like
all the hymns of the church were written
you know in the fourth century that's
absurd all the all the hagiography was
not written right away all the you know
all the iconography programs all the
traditions all the small tea traditions
you know slowly accumulated in the
church and we're added and we're we're
prune and we're removed but it's not
about the new
in the sense of the new having any value
it's more you know something appears the
which can just recognize whether the
tradition is having value and then we'll
slowly be integrated into the tradition
but it's it ends up being a slow organic
process and one of the things that I
like about the Orthodox Church is that
hopefully although you know there are
signs that they might cave at some point
hopefully they're not going to be
bullied by the modern world and changing
for change and you know of letting of
letting in things that are new just
because they're new that is just as it's
think about it think about that idea
think about the idea that so just
because something is new that it has
value it is it is patently absurd it is
completely crazy it has it has it has it
makes no sense sorry sorry AJ to kind of
get on you like that there okay here we
go so norm called they asked hey
Jonathan and your conversation with
Benjamin Bush you said your frame rate
which interpret the world is lacking you
need something which is more connective
and connects the different layers of
reality together what are the different
layers of reality and do they connect
through a unity multiplicity the economy
yes well they don't they connect through
they connect through yes exactly so you
can understand the the layers of reality
as let's say the lower parts become one
and they manifest the higher part of
reality but then that higher part of
reality can also become one with another
aspect which is higher and a simple way
to understand it is of course in terms
of in terms of a society so you have you
you have let's say you let's say you
have your your passions inside you that
are all multiple and then they come into
one and then you manifest the person and
then that that person is in a family and
that family comes into one and if it's
the family those families are one and
then multiple and all those families
come into one and they manifest a higher
level which could be the city that city
comes up manifests
haier which could be the state and keep
going until you get to humanity itself
to man with it with a capital m and so
that is what I mean by levels of reality
that's not the only hierarchy that
exists there are multiple hierarchies
you know that have multiple and
indefinite levels actually but that's a
way to kind of understand it so a way to
know if something is true or something
is real is that you you you can if you
see a pattern then you can try to find
examples that are on a reality above you
and a reality above your interpretation
or your intuition or reality that is
below or find a pattern in which the
same let's say a structure in which the
same pattern is appearing at different
levels and that's one of the ways to
know if something is true or if it's not
if it's just your illusion you know
alright so Kevin Patterson says how can
we navigate the ideas of eschatology
from both within the church and time
prophecies second Advent and from the
secular world environmental collapse
without falling prey to alarmist fear
mongers nihilistic defeatism or
all-encompassing systems this is where I
think this is where I I think that
really the idea of your life of your own
passions of your own of dealing with
your own thing this is where it comes
into play you know this is where I do
agree with Jordan Peterson completely
that you know change yourself work on
yourself first and that will prevent you
from falling into alarmism because it
doesn't matter if the world is gonna end
next week
Christ would not Christ would not have
said thus Christ said spoke as if the
world was gonna end next week right when
Christ was talking about the end times
he was saying like it's neck it's next
week guys it's gonna it's next week and
and and a good way to say it still say
it that way it's like it's happening
right now it's next week guys it's the
end the end so live your life as if it's
the end I live your life as if you're
gonna die too
that's that's where that the purpose of
eschatology the purpose of eschatology
is so that so that you participate in
reality you participate in your life
that you love your neighbor that you
worship God that you that you take this
seriously you know and so yes it is
useful it can be useful to recognize the
sign of the times mostly so that were
not seduced by you know the [ __ ] of
Babylon or that we're not seduced by the
Beast you know when those things
manifest themselves around us but in the
end it's all about you it's all about
you becoming a better person that's
always the core now it's always the
answer so when you see people who when
you see and you see it a lot you see
people who are completely taken up by
eschatology you know it's like the
people who and I made a few videos about
this like people who want to who are
obsessed with like secret societies and
obsessed with the Illuminati and with
all these these things and they're like
are spending hours and hours you know
finding this Luciferian message in this
or that meteor this or that thing it's
like dude seriously I mean it's good to
understand the basic pattern of it and
it's good to point to it but at some
point like your obsession to do that
it's it's disturbing because that's not
what we should be focusing on ultimately
right so that's how I feel about that
kind of stuff I feel like people who
focus too much on eschatology are are
probably doing it as a way to to make to
put the demon outside right - to make
the bad guys something out there that I
have to fight and that I don't have to
look back inside and find those demons
that are affecting me all right so JM
asks hi Jonathan can you explain the
symbolism of the snake in Orthodox
aren't especially regards to the bishops
Crozier and to the icons that depict
Christ crucified as having snake-like
qualities I know that healing by snake
has
president precedent in the story Moses
but this imagery still makes me quite
uncomfortable well look I'm not gonna
answer that right now but what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna point you to an article
that I wrote which is quite long it's
called the serpents of Orthodoxy so you
can look it up it's on the Orthodox
Arsenal and there I go quite deep into
the symbolism of the serpent why Christ
looks like a serpent on the cross why
there's a snake on the top of the
crosier
how it relates to the bronze serpent how
it relates to this new snake in the
garden and the snake that appears in the
icon of the Last Judgement all of that I
deal with all of it so check it out all
right Jeremy Morgan asks all right he
gives me a suggestion for a future video
sorry I should read this little bit ryan
Pinkham asks can you explain the
symbolism of tongues I'm Catholic and
there's a charismatic movement in my
parish that troubles me but I don't know
enough about it to decide if he's
completely heretical I watch a talk
about a monk on my nathas that could
speak to people that didn't speak the
same language that seems correct to me
Jewish not so much thanks yes yes I I
totally agree with you
I totally agree with you obviously you
know the the you can see there are two
there are two kind of versions of the
symbolism of tongues you see it in acts
where this is the one that you saw in
Maya those which seems to be actually
the one that reveals the mystery of the
Incarnation much more which is the idea
of people who have the gift of speaking
in languages that they don't know or
they have the gift of speaking and other
people understand them despite the fact
that it's not their language that seems
to be what Christianity is about it
seems to be the Christianity is is the
thing which can you know not a
universalism in the sense of swallowing
all the malt all the particulars into
itself like kind of sucking them up and
and just becoming one thing but rather
that it can reach into other languages
and that it has the capacity to
be translated into all the different
cultures and have its own you know have
to have each you know culture become a
member of the body and in that sense so
without negating multiplicity so that
seems to be far more in tune with what
we see in acts but there is also in in
the in scripture the idea of speaking
the tongues of angels and you see that
in st. Paul the description of we know
when he talks about how the people who
speak tongues should have someone to
interpret or else you know they're doing
it in vain or whatever and this is
really interesting because this is where
you see and I've talked about this the
problem of the extremes you know when I
talk about the idea of the fool or the
clown and I talk about how you know the
idea of let's say the crown of thorns
with thorns as the root as the fall this
notion that the periphery is like a
circle which goes lower and higher then
then then what's in the middle right
it's kind of like this it's like the
crown above is also the horns of the
animal this deaf right and so it's the
same word it's this it's the same thing
so so this is I think seems to be an
example of where there really is this
confusion where the the language of
angels which should be the highest
language ends up being flipping or not
flipping but ends up becoming appearing
as this this dislike this confused
gibberish this Tower of Babel gibberish
and the idea that people could get into
this gibberish this kind of tower Babel
gibberish and somehow think that this is
a this is like this like this divine
revelation is absolutely nonsense and
it's absolute it's absolutely nonsense
that it's it contradicts everything
about how the world is made it's
completely it's completely insane to
think that this would somehow you know
that now you also have to be careful you
also have to be careful the problem is
that
if it would not be completely
unfathomable
to imagine that someone could appear to
be saying things that are gibberish but
then ultimately they would be
manifesting a the highest pattern but I
think that this is kind of like when I
talk about the holy fool now the problem
is that because our world is so level we
don't understand hierarchies then we
confuse the regular fool with the holy
fool
we think that the fool is always a holy
fool the fool is not always a holy fool
and most of the time 99% of the time
gibberish is gibberish and in those
churches I am pretty sure that gibberish
is gibberish because these charismatic
churches that split every other two
years and that you know that they
they're constantly breaking up and there
have these contradictory prophecies and
all this stuff is just so the tongues
are just another sign of this this
absolute fragmentation of these
non-denominational churches that are all
over the place and that are all you know
saying different things and having all
these different visions and all this
stuff so so it's like that the tongues
are just an example of that but like I
said we if you saw someone speaking the
highest patterns of reality and you
didn't have access to them they might
look like gibberish and I'll give you an
example and then again I don't want to
bring it back on me this is not I'm not
saying I speak in tongues but there are
some videos that have gotten more views
that say and those videos when they they
kind of reach into the algorithm of
YouTube and especially if it's a video
where I'm talking to you guys where I'm
talking to the people who follow my
videos who have developed this this
symbolic structure this symbolic
language they hear me talk about
symbolism and you can see in the
comments are like blah blah blah
gibberish gibberish gibberish they think
that I'm spouting absolute gibberish
they because they don't see the pattern
then when I when I when I speak the
pattern and I talked about these
analogies they just see nonsense
and so so we have to be careful too
because the
highest pattern for those who don't
understand the might look like gibberish
not that they are there not there the
very opposite of gibberish hope that
makes sense
feel like I've confused you guys answer
well we'll see okay okay so so some
people say that we need to act as if God
exists that we need to take the wisdom
of religion but that we can lose the
belief in God
I find this presumptuous much like how
science tries to account for the margins
as God is first and foremost a mystery
what do you think about the idea that
the belief in God is itself and allowing
for the margins I'm not sure that this
has to do with the margins but I can I
can answer that idea you know that even
Jordan you know my friend he says that
he says that he acts as if God exists
this is how I've been thinking about
this actually quite a bit and I and I
think that my answer to that is that I
would say yeah okay you should act as if
God exists even if you do if you
struggle to believe in God you should
start by acting as if God exists but the
problem is that acting as if God exists
does not first and foremost imply
morality doesn't first and foremost
imply a code of behavior it first and
foremost implies worship and so I would
say that if you have if you struggle
like if you if you're struggling with
faith and you you can't get yourself to
believe in God I would say yeah act as
if God exists worship and you're gonna
see what's gonna happen right you're
gonna see what's going to happen and you
see that in the church fathers they
actually talk about that they they talk
about the monk who is dried up and and
and his faith is dry and he can't get
himself to to engage extension with God
and they tell those monks to
to sing the Psalms things I saw seeing
the songs out loud and that's what the
Psalms are like the songs are just
worship it's like it's this recognizing
of that which is higher the celebration
of that which is above you you know and
I think that if if people actually did
that instead of just jumping to morality
I think that we'd had to have surprises
in terms of what would happen to them
and they might they might find faith in
a surprising moment so Neil the grade
asks I always have too many questions to
narrow down to what I want to ask how
about this instead what new thoughts are
you having or what theory or concept
have you been wrestling with of late
well I told you a little bit I've been
thinking about I always want to try to
take on the hardest reality like I
always want to take on the thing that I
feel like atheist or secular wrists have
have kind of brandished and are using to
uh to make fun of Christianity or using
to and that a lot of Christians will
kind of tiptoe around or shy around and
like no I want to take that on so so the
idea of talking about you know what it
means to be a cuckold and what what that
type of symbolism could suggest that's
actually what I've been thinking about
just in the past week or so and as I'm
getting ready to to make that video so I
mean you probably understand like when I
make a video I just don't turn on the
camera even though I now I improvise I
don't just turn on the camera and start
talking I usually have been thinking
about it for months sometimes years you
know at the least weeks that I've been
thinking about it mulling it over trying
to structure my idea so that when I do
sit in front of the camera and and speak
then it comes out in a way that is as
clear as possible um
let's just see where we are here
all right it won't work we're not so bad
we're not so bad that's bad all right
okay so we'll Dickie ask and you
elaborate on the world of free thinking
and imagination Christianity
someone raised secular it took a bit of
rebelling against the material world you
defined mysticism of Christianity now
that I found a Center in the church I am
practicing letting my free thinking mind
die in order to acquire the mind of
Christ but the use of my radical
intellect seemed necessary for the
escape from the modern material Egypt
and it's not something that is easy to
let go of I have found that my
imagination is much better at seeing the
patterns of Christianity inside the
symbols and rituals of the modern world
this seems like a healthy synthesis of
obedience and imaginations thanks for
all you do um yeah I think I think that
I think that we need to understand free
thinking differently we need to
understand freedom differently in
general freedom is really misunderstood
in the world the idea is that if you
submit if you find the mind of Christ
you will become the freest thinker free
in the sense of not bound by the things
around you not not bound by the things
below not bound by your own passions by
your own or by just by the rules of
reality you know it's like when when you
acquire the mind of Christ and all of a
sudden you you you end up in a way
standing above the rules and then you
see the reason for the rules and so you
end up following the rules but you do it
in freedom because you're not you
actually see the reasons for the rules
and so it's not like this the rules
aren't something outside of you that are
let's say that are imposing themselves
on you and making you suffer because you
feel like it's this outer thing that is
opposing itself on you it's rather
become something that comes from within
you because as you ascend and you
acquire the mind of Christ
you notice how these things make sense
and so you you you are free in your
submission to them because you're not
actually submitted to them you're
actually just manifesting them you're
you know you're engaging in them you're
kind of entering into them so I hope
that makes sense um so the idea that you
would apply the things the insights that
you've had of Christ to the modern world
I think is is great I think everybody
needs to keep do
because the reason the fact that people
haven't been able to do that is one of
the reasons why Christianity has been
thrown out because people thought that
at some point thought it just wasn't
talking about anything it's just like
what do you what is this referring to
okay so Justin Seligman asked hi
Jonathan in your November Q&A you
mentioned William of Ockham in the 14th
century as a reason for the
disintegration of the sacramental
Christian worldview you trace his
radical nominalism on to the Reformers
especially Luther Calvin and Cranmer and
if so do any of the products and
traditions of the capacity of recovering
that sacramental view of reality today
thank you for all your work yes I do of
course Luther was a a nominalist the
Luther was an alchemist it's something
that we cannot deny and it is clear that
the way that he understood God as you
know this arbitrary being came straight
from Occam there are many things about
Luther which obviously took from akhom
in that tradition and so um I do think
that it's there in Protestantism and but
it's like anything that it's always a
hierarchy there's always a hierarchy and
so I think that everybody can
participate to a certain extent in the
reate the real sacramentality of reality
the real what did I just say the real
sacramentality of reality that just
participate in the sacramentality of
reality but it's just on a hierarchy I
do I will not lie I've said it several
times before I do believe that the
Orthodox tradition is the Christian
tradition that has stayed closest to the
patterns that has stay closest to the
mind of the father's to the mind of of
Christ but I am NOT one of those that
thinks that there's nothing below
because that doesn't seem like that's
the Orthodox way anyways is it all
participates in God to a certain extent
and so it's just a hierarchy and so I
think that I think that I think that
even in Protestantism there's a
hierarchy there are different they're
different levels there are some churches
which are further from from
truly participating in this the fullness
of the patterns and there are some which
are on the margins and juggling in
playing circus you know and so it just
it just it all yeah just all depends all
right all right so here k asks three
questions let me just choose one of the
three all right here's a good one all
right
so K says I find it hard to interpret
the biblical text without providing
reasons for events from other narratives
within the text I do this with a lot
when thinking of Cain and Abel because
of the little information given did Abel
in some way steal Cain's birthright haha
like Jacob with Esau Abel's blood crying
out from the ground Joseph's calling out
to his father from Egypt is this thought
process wrong no okay this thought
process is not wrong you are right on
track this is the way to do it is you
have to understand the other stories
let's say you have the story of Genesis
as kind of everything gathered into the
seed you know even right there in the
first days of creation you have the
whole thing kind of packed into a very
very spiritual way of saying it and then
it unfolds in all the other stories and
so what happens is in the later stories
you find examples which manifests the
patterns more explicitly that have more
meat to it and then that can then give
you insight in understand in
understanding the earlier patterns if
you didn't have the capacity to perceive
all the implications of the early
patterns and so you can understand it
that way it's like in the early stories
everything is all the implicit
associations are gathered in and then
those implicit associations become
explicit as all the other stories appear
and so it can help you understand the
implicit in the first stories and so
your example is a great example you are
right to see that there's a relationship
between K
enable Jacob and Esau Jacob tries to
kill he saw sorry Lisa tries to kill
Jacob just like Cain killed Abel
and now the idea that did so you have to
understand that it's it's the same but
it's not the same right and so you can
understand that Cain and Abel have this
Cain and Abel show the pattern and then
Jacob and Esau show it in a specific
angle which is this idea that the the
reason why let's say Jacob supplanted
Esau was by stealing his birthright and
so in a way there's something negative
about that but whereas in the story at
the beginning the reason why Abel is
chosen is because his sacrifice is was
accepted by God and so you what it helps
you to see is that like I always tell
you guys but patterns aren't moral and
so you find the same pattern sometimes
in in which the terms one of the terms
is seen as more negative and the same
pattern can appear where one of the same
term is seen as more positive and so it
just depends on the story and so you
when you seeing that in a way they're
related but they're not exactly the same
can help you to kind of click and see
the pattern which is above it to see the
pattern which by which all those stories
are kind of showing themselves so I hope
this this but I would say your honor
you're on a good track cuz which you've
both of those examples in terms of
Joseph calling from Egypt and and Abel's
blood calling from the ground is perfect
because that's exactly echip represents
the ground Egypt also represents the
ground alright so Somalia Bell says in
Romans 13 Paul says that we should
submit to our rulers and pair taxes
because all authority comes from God one
of my friend interprets that passages
being against democracy and pro monarchy
democratically elected leaders are being
put in position of power by the plebs
contrary to monarchs that derive their
right to rule from God that
interpretation democracy could be seen
as an ongoing revolt against God's will
symbolically could be
that the body refuses to submit to the
head would you agree with that reading
if not why I agreed to it to a certain
extent I'm not a big fan of the
Democratic idea there often is a kind of
democracy it just it just often doesn't
go all the way down you know the let's
say that the King often will end up
being kind of chosen by the aristocracy
you know or recognized by the
aristocracy so you can understand that
the election as a recognising of
something which is already true right
you can understand it that way so you
have you have the the aristocrats
recognize who is going to be the king
because of some proud prowess because
that person was able to lead lead the
people in battle or whatever reason that
a king ends up getting chosen and so you
could see it that way you could see it
that way even for an election I think
that that I think that even though the
democratic process this idea of cycling
through leaders every four years and and
the I and the idea that the people have
the power I think is indeed what you
said it is a revolt
it is a revolt thinking it is
revolutionary thinking but nonetheless I
still believe that even though that's
what it is this recognition this
legitimacy this legitimizing principle
even though I think it it's lacking in
terms of its in terms of its ontological
strength let's say is nonetheless the
one we have and so I think we still have
to submit to our leaders I think that in
a democracy you still have to submit
your leaders even though the the the
democratic process of these elections
and this idea that people are the power
and all these things is is somewhat
misleading um that's the legitimately
that's the legitimate little
legitimizing process by which our
society chooses their leaders for now
and so pay your taxes and submit to your
leaders because they're still chosen by
God sorry to tell you even though
they're elected they're still chosen by
God you can't avoid it does it mean that
they won't cause scandal doesn't mean
that they won't
the world to their ruin you know but God
knows that the world is going to its
ruin and you know that's with that
that's a that's part of the pattern all
right all ger Erickson asks why do the
cherubim have so many wings and faces
and why is one guarding the Garden of
Eden
I mean I'm gonna make a video about that
for sure um the cherub the cherub is a
is is really like a sphinx the cherub is
really something like a hybrid it's it's
something like a monster it has you know
different heads or different animals
sometimes it has different body parts of
different animals it's described
differently in different aspects of in
different parts of Scripture and it's
guarding the Garden of Eden because it's
on the edge it's like a gargoyle
it's on the outside and it's guarding
the inside so you can understand that at
every transition there's a monster the
transition of the different even so you
have the transition from the outside to
the inside but there are different
insides and so you can have a cherub on
the on the at the gate of Eden then you
could have a cherub on the veil of the
of the Holy of Holies because all of
these all of these are transitions from
insides to outsides right all of these
are these buffer zones between two
distinct distinct levels of the
hierarchy and in those buffer zones
that's where the monsters are hiding and
so I often tell you that the monsters
are hiding on the edge of the world and
they are but they also are hiding at
every level where there's a distinction
in the hierarchy so at there the edge of
every world not just the whole world but
every smaller world also has monsters on
its edge and so that's why in the image
of the of the the the garden you have a
cherub on the edge of the garden because
that's the edge that's what the edges
the edges this hybrid creature that
guards the that guards the transition
right and so you can understand the
garden you can understand the cherub and
the sword the flaming sword has two
opposites on the edge of the world so on
the edge of the world you have two
things
the edge of the world you have mixture
and you have a cut-off you have the
place where it gets cut off so but in
between identities there's a buffer
there's a there's a place where
identities have a kind of mixing but
then there's also a place where it gets
chopped off and it's like that's it
that's the end no more right and so you
can understand so so you can see in
modernity you have the two extremes that
are manifesting themselves
you have the cherub which is mixture
crazy mixture and confusion then you
also have the flaming sword which is
absolute identity absolute purity those
two are modern and those two are like
these the an image of the end right as
this this this type of manifestation as
the cherub and the flaming sword become
more and more pronounced he would say
that we can see we're going towards a
bigger end or a bigger edge of the world
so I hope that makes sense so you can
imagine like if you can imagine the the
cherub with a flaming sword like a
cherub holding a flaming sword that's
like the ultimate edge it's like you
know the two contradictions brought into
one the ultimate end is a cherub with a
flaming sword both absolute mixture
absolute separation which seems like an
impossible thing but that's the image of
the end the end of the world
um I running out of running out of time
here guys
skip some of these some of these are a
little long so the Limbourg brothers
depict the snake in the garden is
feminine I've seen this in other Western
artists as well what does this symbolic
presentation reveal and is it
symbolically small o Orthodox
yeah the usually when the snake is
represented as feminine it usually is an
image of Lilith and so Lilith is this
it's kind of this it's in its I think it
comes mostly from Judaism and these
later traditions that Adam had a wife
before Eve and that this wife before Eve
because she didn't you know she didn't
submit to Adam then she ended up
spawning all these monsters like self
spawning all these monsters and demons
and all this stuff um and you can
understand it as I've talked about this
before in several of my talks where
there's that there's a there's a notion
that that which is before your origin is
akin to that which is on the edge both
of them have the appearance of of chaos
and of monsters because they're not part
of the system so it's like that which
was before he's not connected to your
story and so it appears chaotic and and
and and fragmented in all this stuff and
that which is a after your story or
beyond your story also doesn't fit in
the story and so it also has this
chaotic fringe and so I think that
that's what that's what Lilith is and
the serpent is that as well serpent is
you know the arroba rose around the
trees around the world the snake around
the tree all of these images are
representing the same thing and this
idea of like a wife that that Adam would
have had before before before Eve is
this pre origin thing where all the
monsters come from right where you know
the idea of the gods before the
Olympians where the Titans that became
Titans and are these monsters on the
edge of the world that are these
elemental forces and these elemental
monsters so it's just trying to have the
same structure in the scripture now is
it small or Orthodox I would say I would
say don't
teach your children that like it's very
very very small to Orthodox I think you
can get some insight from that but uh
but I it's not definitely not something
that the church fathers have accepted
all right all right almost done all
right so can you break down the
symbolism of gold frankincense and myrrh
Dru McMahon asked that well hmm I should
probably do a video on that next
Christmas it has to do I need to think
about it a lot more because I you know
the Church Fathers give this description
of it which is that you know the gold
represents Christ royalty the incense
represents his priesthood and the myrrh
represents kind of both in a way
represents his embalming or his death
but also it also represents kind of like
even his divinity or represents the
highest aspect of him this is something
that you see in the tradition and so
it's it's that type of of simba
symbolism is not my favorite type of
symbolism because I feel like it lacks
it lacks a connection to - to the
pattern but I it might just be my
incapacity to see it and so I I have to
think about it and and I'll get back to
you I maybe I'm sorry to say it might be
next Christmas but that making a good
video for next Christmas and I'll have
thought about it quite a bit by that
time all right guys so so there are a
few more questions from people that
already ask questions so I'm gonna skip
those and I am going to go and see if
just a few to see if there are a few
super chats and get through those
and we'll see all right let's see this
okay we go so okay so all right so
anonymous 50 DKK corona I don't know
what that means in my my my currency but
thank you hey Jonathan I love your stuff
would you say that you are worried or
hopeful regarding the future of our
societies around the world I would say
that I am both worried and hopeful at
the same time I think that things are
not looking great and I think that
things are looking like they're gonna
get darker but I also do believe that
it's just part of the part of the story
and that out of it is going to come a
resurrection you know and I and I
already see I feel like I see glimmers
of it already and I see in some aspects
I see people we you know you already see
you see like these intellectuals all of
a sudden realizing the inevitability of
God and the inevitability of religion
and they're struggling still struggling
with it you know you see all these kind
of secularists who who who can see that
they can't avoid it but they're angry
and they don't want to fully accept it
but I think that this is just the first
step and so I think we're gonna see more
of that and add evening of that but at
the same time the world is crazy and
we're gonna see a lot more of that too
hopefully there'll be enough of a are of
a remainder to get you know to get the
spark going again so Christian sacra
asked many Christians don't think there
is an issue if they do yoga this is hard
to square for me I wonder if the ogor
could be made Christian any thoughts um
yeah I don't know man
III talked about yoga before I think I
find a shady I wouldn't I wouldn't do
yoga as having said that I don't think
that if you do yoga you're going to hell
or that if you do yoga you'll be
automatically possessed by a demon but I
think that there's something fragmentary
about the way
the moderns and kind of California
Buddhists types do yoga they're not
Buddhist but whatever California
spiritual types do yoga and and I think
that they misunderstand the original
purpose of yoga and so because they use
something which seemed to be have more
spiritual connotation to just get fit
there's something about it's just it's
just I find it just manifests the kind
of confusion spiritual confusion that we
see around us you know and people
confuse there's so much confusion like
people confused confused that's a
spiritual practice and spiritual and
mysticism with the idea of feeling
better and being relaxed and all this
stuff it's like that's not what it's
about so I'm not a big fan but you know
whatever it's if I meet a Christian who
does yoga usually I'm not gonna say
anything I mean there are worse things
in the world for sure than that so Brad
Pitt Brad Pitt for $10 says how do we
edify the church I try talking about
metaphysics with people but nobody seems
to care it sucks because if I make it
political it would be personal but it's
too divisive so it's not so I would say
it's the best way to go for it is beauty
beauty is not an argument beauty is just
there and so showing the beauty let's
say showing showing the beauty of the
patterns in Scripture let's say in the
church that's something that everybody
loves I've noticed it like it just
depends on how you do it I've when I sit
with like an evangelical pastor usually
by the end of the conversation the
pastor is like is over-the-moon happy
because I'm not there to confront him
I'm not there to criticize the thing I
just want you to see how beautiful this
is
and so I do it in I talked about you
know Scripture and I point out the
different parallels that they might not
have thought about and it's like I'm
giving him food that he can then use in
his own sermons that he can use in his
in his own stuff and usually they're
excited about it so I think that beauty
is the best way to go about it
I found that arguing with people is
really useful it can be sometimes some
people some people change to that type
of arguing or and talking about
metaphysics is really is really too
abstract if you understand the
metaphysical aspect of Christianity then
you should be able to apply it and you
should be able to manifest it rather
than just talk about it and so like I
said love and beauty
so Jonathan ought what is the symbolism
of centers of world moving world power
moving West Greece to Rome to Europe you
the European colonial powers such as the
UK etc well this is something that was
in the in the late Middle Ages it was a
very popular theory and it was the idea
that that the world is moving west and
you know kind of like the cycle is
moving west
I think there's something to say about
that I don't think it's I think it's
some of it is problematic but I I do
think that that it does seem to be a
basic pattern of this moving towards
West especially with the discovery of
America and moving to America and then
you know even you know states like
California which really seem to be a
microcosm of everything that's going on
in the world you know at the western tip
of civilization and so I think that
there's definitely and the idea that
also that California is on a fault line
you know this whole idea of that it
could just break off and fall into the
sea it's like it's all symbolism happens
to me so I I do think that it is
something worth worth thinking about and
also seeing how this movement towards
West becomes more and more let's say
material becomes more and more focused
on on concrete things and less and less
capable of seeing spiritual reality
moving towards kind of this this this
this flip between solidity and confusion
alright and so Bruce neh newest forgave
$7 dot seventy-seven Canadian alright
Bruce thanks without a question
let me just check it for one last one
popped in and if not all right hey I
didn't think I was gonna make it and we
did it in an hour and a half not bad I
would say so I want to thank all the
moderators I know it always gets pretty
crazy in there in the chat it's like I
don't know how you guys do it how do you
guys listen to what I'm saying and at
the same time write all this stuff I
don't know how that works I don't think
I could do that which is why I struggle
to even like glance at the chat while
all of this is going on oh man Jacob and
Lisa say we don't listen sorry guys and
so you guys this is like pure self
sacrifice on your part I really
appreciate it so hopefully so hopefully
so now I know why Lisa wants to make the
click channel because she doesn't get to
listen during the Q&A is if she's a
moderator she has to listen to them
again and then make those clips ha ha
all right guys so I appreciate
everything I thank everybody who is
supporting me it's been it's been a
crazy crazy year there's one last thing
that's going on I think I mentioned
before but I'm gonna mention it again
one of the big projects this year is
going to be to to create a kind of
platform for symbolic thinking on my
website where we're going to be
publishing articles and publishing short
things long things you know articles
that are just simple interpretations of
movies or things going on and all of it
is going to most of it's going to come
from the people who are involved in the
Facebook group there are a few people
that are really actively involved in
have just developed a really powerful
into it intuition and so so that's how
it's gonna start and then once we kind
of get started then anybody will be able
to you can submit articles and if
they're good then we might consider them
and but that's gonna be a little further
down into the future
so guys thank you for your attention and
I'll see everybody next month again bye
bye